>> Okay, so it is another well-founded induction because we've
shrunk the lengths of the things that we're comparing recursively. in,
in logic this would look like x is the value at
position 1 of x does not equal the value in position 1 in y,
that's our condition here and there, what we had before about the position x so
there existed j. j is greater than one, j is less than the length of y
where x of 1 equals y of j and it must be the case that
there's a permutation between the tail of x. Leaving out the first element and
the results of pasting together y from 1 up to j minus 1 with the result,
with the the third segment which was from j plus 1 through the end of, end of y.
And the little funny symbol with, looks like a cap hair is pasting together and
the real name for that is concatenation. We can concatenate two vectors together
using this operator and if those conditions all hold then we'll,
then what we're defining x to be a permutation of y.